Could you see that?
Yeah.
Come together.
There's a logical explanation.
It's a ghost.
What?
So we're dealing with a,
uh...
Ghostwriter?
My pocket watch has stopped.
If you don't mind I'd
appreciate the time.
There's a talking rabbit
that nobody can see but us.
I think the ghost who was
sending us messages
also sent us the rabbit.
This way.
You're gonna think
this is bizarre,
but what if your
grandma is Ghostwriter?
She did bring us all together.
Grandpa said even though
grandma's gone
she’ll always be with us.
Your grandma had
this old letter.
She even kept it in a fancy box.
Secret letter?
Did y'all say you need
help finding something?
‘Cause I'm real good
at finding stuff.
I don't think grandma
wanted anyone to find this.
Until now.
The letter was signed “S."
Who's “S”?
What was that?
A clue from Ghostwriter.
Follow what?
Follow the money.
A check?
If we can see the
signature
we'll know if that guy is “S."
You knew Ruben's grandma?
She was sure that
this bookstore was haunted.
So if your grandma knew
there was a ghost
in the bookstore...
Then maybe she's not the ghost.
Woah.
GW's painting.
Cobalt Mask?
There's no author in here.
That's a first.
This is gonna be interesting.
Rumor has it
there's an unpublished
Mason Briggs manuscript.
That's Ghostwriter.
He's back.
Maybe it's the
number of the storage unit.
This must be the typewriter
he used to write the manuscript.
What else can be
written on a typewriter?
A secret letter?
Mason Briggs wrote this
letter to my grandma.
Mason Briggs is a made-up name.
You are correct.
Mason Briggs is a pseudonym.
I can't believe we hit
another dead end.
Ew, don't touch random
things on the subway.
Check it out.
This newspaper's
from the future.
Everything in this book
has built to this moment.
High stakes
and full of suspense.
Can you believe GW's
sending us on a
time travel mystery?
Yes, I can.